someone stop by that I am really excited
to meet as you may know I'm from Boston
so I'm particularly excited to meet this
gentleman he's a running back for the
New England Patriots and he just broke a
Super Bowl record by scoring 20 points
three touchdowns and a two-point
conversion he also broke the record for
most receptions in a Super Bowl with 14
I just have to say hi to him because
he's just here briefly it's my pleasure
my great pleasure to welcome sweetfeet
James White let's get him out here
[Applause]
I am so excited to meet you I lost my
mind watching this game I watched it
with my son and we were pretty sure this
wasn't gonna work out and it turned out
to be the greatest Superbowl comeback in
history did the team ever give up
I'm just curious at one point when you
guys were down I think was 28 to 3
weren't you secretly thinking all right
let's just start making vacation plans
let's get a restaurant reservation this
isn't going to happen no never that I
mean we have guys on our team that are
gonna fight to the end no matter where
up 40 points are down 40 points so
nobody was yelling they're screaming
guys are motivate on the sidelines and
eventually we just kept decreasing the
deficit and we eventually got in the
game and we want it so it was crazy
did you decide not to look at the
scoreboard because I think and you I
would just I always put myself in
because I'm an amazing athlete I always
put myself
[Applause]
well I don't know why you're laughing so
hard that's all I do
that's do that I'm just thinking you
wouldn't look I would just not look if I
were in your position I wouldn't even
look up the scoreboard cuz that would
just freak me out
yeah at one point I just stopped looking
up and I mean if we score touchdowns and
defense guy stops I know eventually
somehow we'd be back in the game
yeah and then the fourth quarter be
right there high tire made a big strip
sack I think that really gave us all the
momentum we need all right once you
start that momentum going all right we
have a clip here of the game-winning
touchdown let's take a look at it first
and talk about it
[Applause]
I get really excited watching that how
excited do you get watching that or are
you just remembering how nervous you
were at the time I get nervous watching
it too really because I mean when you
when they called the play and Brady said
you're gonna take the ball how did that
feel I felt like everything kind of went
into slow motion for me it's what you
dream about as a kid having an
opportunity to win the game for your
football team and I'm like here's my
moment right I just want to do anything
I could to get the ball in the end zone
and when I did it I kind of went crazy I
left the ball you left the ball I've
told the ball is missing is that right
that is true I don't know this is crazy
braid the shirt that Brady was wearing
is missing and your ball is missing
what's going on there's some slit guys
in the in the crowd I just might be one
guy there's one guy walking around
wearing cradies Jersey holding your ball
you think police could catch that person
that's an easy guy to find whose guy
walking around town
you must be a great athlete
you